بالدبابات والمدافع تركز الدول الغربيه
على دعمك بولندا انها تدرس نقل عدد من
دبابات ليوبار الى اوكرانيا بالتعاونيه مع
دول غربيه اخرى وبحسب الاذاعه البولنديه
فقط ارسلت السلطات البولنديه اكثر من 200
دبابه من تراس تيتاني 7 و10 من عربات
القتاليه الى اوكرانيا وتوقعت بولندا
استلام دبابات ليوبار الالمانيه حيث يمتلك
الجيش البولندي 126 دبابه من طراز تو
ايفون
و105 دبابات من طراز تو اي 5 من جهاتها
اعلنت المانيا انها لا تستبعد التسليم
دبابات ليوبال وهي مركبات قتاليه اثقل من
مركبات ماردر لدعم القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في المستقبل كما تدرس بريطانيا
تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات لاول مره بعد ما
كانت المناقشات جاريه لضعت اسابيع حول
تسليم دبابه القتال الرئيسيه تشالنجر
التابعه للج بريطانيا
[موسيقى]